[Music]
Hawaii is grappling this morning with an
alarming increase in snorkel related
deaths ten people have died since
January on average 17 people die each
year in Hawaii while snorkeling a
full-face snorkel mask is at the center
of one theory about the rise in deadly
incidents so far this year that type of
gear has been linked to four deaths
Ladda mere duty a of our streaming
network cbsn went to honolulu to learn
why the masks design is raising concerns
good morning here in Hawaii's beaches
lifeguards say they are seeing more and
more of these full face snorkel masks
some of the tourists that we've spoken
to say they love them they say they're
easier to use than conventional massive
snorkels but some safety advocates warn
that people need to know about the risks
that come with wearing these and for one
man's wife that warning came too late
she was a water bug which is a water bug
yeah she was a good swimmer guy Cooper
and his wife Nancy peacock traveled the
world together but on her last trip to
the Hawaiian Islands
Cooper stayed behind at their home in
California he says it haunts him every
day I picked her in the water
frightened panicking trying struggling
with that mask an avid snorkeler peacock
was trying out a new type of equipment a
full face mask she bought on Amazon but
less than an hour after entering the
water her lifeless body was pulled out
by a nearby surfer I started right away
thinking about this mask right away
because I'm trying to think what what
could have gone wrong these masks have a
new design that covers the entire face
allowing snorklers to breathe out of
their nose and mouth unlike the
traditional two-piece snorkel equipment
but some safety experts say it's this
design that may make it less safe with
greater risk for carbon dioxide buildup
that could cause snorklers to become
dizzy or disoriented and tighter fitting
head straps and may make it harder to
pull off in an emergency
something Cooper suspects what happened
to his wife I wrote to the coroner
and I said wouldn't you want to know
what she was using the ER never asked
those questions you've never asked those
questions apparently no one is asking
those questions and couldn't that be a
contributing factor but until last year
the type of equipment used in snorkel
related deaths or near deaths was never
recorded no one will know if they're
dangerous or not until you put it in a
database look for trends this is ground
zero for Hawaii's ground why is ground
zero for the snorkeling related
incidence Ralph Gotoh recently retired
as Honolulu's director of ocean safety
after 30 years he now co-chairs a
committee investigating the spike in
snorkel related deaths along with the
Hawaii Department of Health there's the
full face mask theory there's issues of
pre-existing medical conditions there's
theories of inexperience and all of them
have some credence so we're asking the
first responders to gather the equipment
that's involved in these cases but as
for the masks more and more people are
using the full face mask lifeguards like
Kawika Eckhart and his team are
responsible for the safety of an average
of 2,600 visitors each day at Hanauma
Bay he says it's too early to know if
they put snorklers in greater danger
we're looking into if there is a
connection to snorkel drownings and and
the full face mask have you tried one of
these yes and what you think no comment
one manufacturer of the full face mask
had USA said in a statement the safety
of our customers and the performance of
our equipment have always been our first
priorities adding the product was put
through rigorous testing protocols
including the measurement of potential
co2 buildup the statement went on to say
their success has spawned a number of
low-cost copycat masks whose expertise
design and manufacturing experience are
unknown it's something that troubles
Robert Whitner founder of snorkel Bob's
one of Hawaii's top snorkel equipment
retailers I get three or four inquiries
a week from Chinese manufacturers you
must carry these please send your
address we'll send samples and my
response is always the same no thank you
please put them in the dumpster
Whitner decided against carrying any of
the full face masks after his
researchers tested them they said that
the face area heats up and gave them a
feeling of claustrophobia they could not
reach their nose to clear its hazardous
and if you try to get the mask off in a
hurry and you're not thinking clearly it
can stick but there are snorkeling
fatalities way before there were one
piece mess I think we have to look at it
in totality is it the snorkel is it the
mask we don't know for certain right now
what's going on but we're certainly
trying to find out Cooper may never know
exactly what caused his wife's death but
for now I just wouldn't want someone
else to go through what I went through
losing her currently there are no
regulations for snorkel equipment in the
United States the Consumer Product
Safety Commission did respond to guy
Cooper's complaint and they say they are
looking into full face masks but they
haven't taken any action Cooper says his
wife Nancy will not have died in vain if
more people are aware of the possible
risks associated with these devices for
CBS this morning
vladimir duthiers honolulu HI glad thank
you